--Fourth annual James R. Killian
Junior Faculty Achievement
Award Lecture.
I'm Krishna Rajagopal,
chair of the faculty.
Before we begin, just
to tell you the program,
it's my guess that the
lecture and the Q&A
afterwards will go until about
5:10, 5:15 along those lines.
And then afterwards there
will be a reception downstairs
in the Bush Room to which
everyone is invited.
The James R. Killian Junior
Faculty Achievement Award
was established in
the spring of 1971
as a permanent tribute
to Dr. James Killian, who
was president of MIT
from 1948 to '59,
and chairman of the corporation
from then until 1971.
The purpose of the
award is to recognize
extraordinary professional
achievement by MIT faculty
members and to communicate
their accomplishments to members
of the Institute writ large.
The title of Killian
Lecturer is the highest honor
that the MIT faculty may
bestow on one of its own.
It is our privilege today
to honor and welcome
Tyler Jacks, the David H.
Koch Professor of Biology
and the director of the Koch
Institute-- the Koch Institute
for Integrative Cancer
Research at MIT.
As noted by his colleagues on
the Killian award committee,
professor Jacks has long been
a pioneer in the MIT cancer
research community.
His early achievements in
genetically engineering mouse
models that closely
replicate the human disease
allowed certain types
of tumors to be studied
with greater reliability.
And today the
models he developed
are used in labs worldwide,
contributing to a better
understanding of disease
pathogenesis and progression,
and enabling the testing of
novel anticancer strategies.
Both in and out of the
lab, professor Jacks
is described by colleagues
as bold and visionary.
His nominators point
out that it takes
a village of passionate
and dedicated people
to invent solutions for
the many cancers that
afflict our society,
and they point out
this is exactly what he has
created over in building 76.
Yet as one colleague commented,
"successes like the Koch
Institute do not just happen.
They are created through
dynamic leadership."
And this is one of the qualities
for which we honor and thank
Professor Jacks today.
Since 2001 when he was selected
to direct the center that
would become the
Koch Institute, he
has foster
transformative changes
by cultivating
multi-disciplinary
collaboration between cancer
biologists and engineers.
Today the Koch Institute houses
dozens of faculty research
groups and serves
as an organizing
body for more than 500
researchers at MIT.
Faculty and student cite his
mentorship and his commitment
to bringing the different
cultures and languages
and research agendas of these
two communities, these two
worlds together.
He also does a marvelous
job of reaching out
to the larger world outside
MIT, communicating challenges
over common lessons learned at
the cancer research frontier
to broad audiences.
For example, and I can
personally recommend this,
through a TEDx Cambridge
talk that he gave back
in September of 2014.
Professor Jacks
joined the MIT faculty
in 1992, and in the years
since he's been recognized
with numerous awards.
He's been named a Howard
Hughes Investigator
and received the Paul Marks
prize for cancer research.
He was elected to two
of the nation's most
prestigious academies, the
National Academy of Sciences
and the Institute
of Medicine in 2009.
That same year he was elected
president of the American
Association of Cancer
Research and he
was appointed chair of the
National Cancer Institute's
National Cancer advisory
board in 2011, and in 2012
was elected to the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences.
So it's a privilege
and a pleasure
to welcome Tyler
Jacks to the lectern.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
And now I get to actually
give you the certificate.
I have the mic for
another second.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
So Tyler, it is my privilege
to represent the MIT faculty
in honoring you with the James
R. Killian Faculty Achievement
Award, through
which we recognize
your influence on the field
of cancer research achieved
through your own
pioneering work,
and your visionary leadership
to unite MIT's cancer biologists
and engineers in a collaborative
multi-disciplinary research
community.
Congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, thanks Krishna for that
very, very nice and generous
introduction.
At the appropriate
time I'm happy for you
to deliver my eulogy.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to thank Professor
Rigobon and the Killian award
committee for selecting
me for this honor.
It's a tremendous honor I
must say, in part because it's
given to me by my
peers, and in part
because it represents the great
tradition of our university.
I'm frankly blown away to see
my name on the list of Killian
award recipients.
I'm not sure I
belong there, but I'm
happy to be there just the same.
This award is particularly
meaningful to me
because I have an extremely
long history at MIT.
I came here in 1988 to pursue
my post-doctoral studies
with Bob Weinberg in
the Whitehead Institute,
and joined the faculty in 1992.
So that's a span in
total of 28 years.
Quite remarkable.
Of course I started when
I was nine, so that's OK.
My brother is a graduate of
this institute, class of 1976.
And some of you know that my
father was a faculty member
here for 30 years,
starting in the late 1950s
until his retirement
in the 1980s.
Rumor has it that I was
conceived on the MIT campus.
I'm not sure that's true.
[LAUGHTER]
A story for another time.
But my dad used to bring
me to MIT when I was a kid.
And I can tell you that
Kendall Square in the 1960s
was a very different place.
There was literally
one place to eat.
It was the F&T Diner.
Some of the old timers will
remember the F&T Diner.
It's where the T station is.
And my dad and I would
go there each time,
and we would always have
pastrami sandwiches.
And I still remember the taste
of those pastrami sandwiches
today.
And my education from MIT
started very early as well.
I learned to play poker
from my father's colleagues
around the table at our house,
and their monthly poker game.
And that included people like
Frank Fisher and Bill Pounds
and Peter Gill and
Howard Johnson actually
used to come-- Howard Johnson,
former president of MIT.
That wasn't a
simpler time, Rafael,
when the president could gamble
with members of the faculty.
[LAUGHTER]
My dad passed away
about 15 years ago,
but I'm quite sure
he would be extremely
proud of today's events.
I want to thank
you all for coming.
I know that you expected a
lecture on gravitational waves,
but I'm--
[LAUGHTER]
--glad your here anyway.
I want to thank
the Koch Institute
folks who gave me a rousing
send-off from the building much
to my surprise.
I walked out the door, there
were 200 people in a gauntlet,
lining the courtyard as I
walked my way over here.
So thanks for that.
That was really
quite a send-off.
I want to thank David
Koch for making the time
to come up from New York
to be with us today.
I want to give a special
welcome to my wife
Laura and my daughter
Libby, and thanks to them
for their never-ending
love and support.
And I want to make a
special thanks to Joe Cohen.
Where is Joe?
I hope he's here.
Joe Cohen was responsible
for all logistics
related to today's event,
including the advertisement.
And Joe advertised the
hell out of this thing.
[LAUGHTER]
I couldn't turn a corner on
campus without seeing my face.
I know what it's like now to be
one of America's Most Wanted.
So thank you for all
of those things things.
And certainly thank you
for the recognition.
I'm being recognized
for two things I guess.
They were mentioned in
Krishna's introduction.
One is the science
that we've performed
and the other is the Koch
Institute development.
And I'm going to talk a bit
about both of those things
today.
With respect to the
science, I think
it's important to point out that
scientific achievement is not
a singular activity.
It's the collective
activity of many people.
And I've been extremely lucky
to attract outstanding people
to work for me over the
last quarter century--
graduate students
like those shown here.
The names and faces of the past
and present graduate students
from my group are shown.
We get wonderful students
at MIT, undergraduates
and graduate students and they
contribute mightily to the work
that we perform in
our laboratories.
Likewise I've had the
privilege of training
a very large number of
outstanding postdoctoral
fellows.
Again the names and
faces of the individuals
presently in the lab and
previously in the lab
are shown here.
And these folks, the post-docs
and the graduate students
have continued to
do great research
in their independent training
and independent careers,
contributing to discoveries
in cancer research
around the world,
across the country,
really carrying things forward.
And I would say
one of my proudest
if not proudest achievements
as a faculty member
is being able to train
these wonderful people.
This is the greatest product
of our laboratory's research.
Students in the post-docs
often get the headlines,
but importantly they are
assisted by technical help,
technical assistance.
We've worked with a number
of great technicians
over the years.
Their names and
faces are shown here.
They deserve a lot of
the credit as well.
And over the years we've
had wonderful undergraduate
students and summer students.
High school students
work with us.
And they contribute as
well, both in the science
that they pursue,
and also as mentees
for the mentors in
the lab so that they
can learn how to
become better teachers,
and to learn the
skills of mentorship.
And finally, the lab runs
because of great people
who helped administer the lab.
And I've been assisted
by wonderful people
over the years.
Shown here, my administrative
assistants and lab managers.
I want to make special
reference to Judy Teixeira who's
sitting in the second row here.
Judy's been with me for 15 years
as my administrative assistant.
The smirk on her
face sort of suggests
that she's tired of
hearing yet one more thing
that I need her to do.
But thank you Judy for all that
you've done over the years.
Now, the introduction
referenced the development
of the Koch Institute.
And the development
of Koch Institute
likewise was a
shared experience.
It was a joint effort,
involving many, many people,
including very importantly
Jackie Lees, who's
the associate director
of the Koch Institute
and was the associate
director of the Center
for Cancer Research
starting back in 2001.
And Jackie and I
really conceived
of changing the course
of cancer research
and including the
engineering community
in that new direction.
We were joined at
that time, 2007,
by Dane Wittrup, who likewise
made major contributions
to the directions
that we finally took
and the planning that
we made at that time.
Phil Sharp was a
major force in that.
Bob Langer, Doug Lauffenburger,
and many others on our factory
contributed significantly
to the progress and planning
that we made.
Cindy Quense is the assistant
director for administration
of the Koch and does a wonderful
job overseeing the headquarters
staff and the operations.
Anne Deconinck and
before her Robert Urban
have served as executive
directors of the Koch,
taking care of many of the
outstanding outreach efforts
that we make in
various directions.
So I'm very indebted
to all of them
and many others who've made
the Koch Institute what
it is today.
This wouldn't have
happened if not
for the support
and encouragement
and massive effort by
the MIT administration.
This happened in 2007 while
Susan Hockfield was president.
Rafael Reif was provost.
And they too
contributed to the idea
of bringing scientists
and engineers together
under one roof.
If not for them we
wouldn't have done it.
And they continue to be
tremendous supporters--
Susan whose office is now
in the Koch Institute.
Raphael as president has
remained a steadfast supporter
of the Koch Institute.
So I'm very grateful to
the MIT administration
for helping us do this.
I'm grateful to
the deans that I've
worked with over the years
in science and engineering,
vice presidents for research,
Claude Canizares, Maria
Zuber who've been
tremendously supportive.
And we wouldn't be here if not
for one specific individual,
and that's David Koch.
David was remarkably
generous in providing
the funds necessary for
us to build the building
that we now occupy,
to provide funds
to equip the building
that we now use,
and has also funded six
professorships along the way.
So David has been
remarkably generous to us
here at MIT for cancer
research, and frankly
around the country in
support of cancer research.
So thank you to you David.
The idea of doing cancer
research in the way
that we now do it in
the Koch Institute
takes advantage
of great strengths
that we have, somewhat
uniquely here at MIT.
Cancer scientists
working together
with cancer-oriented engineers
to encourage new approaches
to longstanding
problems in cancer.
The idea was that there
would be opportunities
at the interfaces of various
disciplines in basic science
and engineering to approach
problems in cancer that
have been very
difficult using singular
approaches in the
past-- that there was
some magic at this interface,
and that we could therefore
make new discoveries,
different kinds of discoveries
and new inventions
and new technologies
through a very deliberate
effort in collaboration,
working across disciplines
to take advantage
of this rather unique
mix of individuals
that we have in the Koch.
And moreover that we
could mobilize our efforts
beyond those discoveries
and new technologies
and deliver those to
the benefit of patients.
Not to stop at the
discoveries at the bench,
but actually to translate
those discoveries
to the benefit of
cancer patients,
to change the lives of patients,
to change the course of cancer.
And frankly I'm pleased to say
that we're starting to do that.
And I'm extremely
proud of that as well.
So 2007, we started
thinking about how
to develop the Koch Institute.
We planned it over the
next couple of years,
again with contributions
from many people,
including folks in the
planning office here at MIT.
And finally in late
2010, early 2011
we open the doors to the
new Koch Institute building.
We brought this project
in, David's proud to say,
under budget and ahead of
schedule-- quite remarkable.
And it was celebrated,
as you can see here
on the front page of the
Boston Globe above the fold.
"A new style of cancer
research coming together,
bringing individuals
from diverse backgrounds
together to approach the
problems in a new way."
I'd like to point out
that in this same page
that this doctor
who was indicted
had nothing to do with us.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm quite sure that he
was a Harvard doctor.
[LAUGHTER]
So we moved in.
And this is what things look
like in building 76 now.
It's a beautiful building.
You've all seen it.
Some of you work inside of it.
And around the rim
are the faculty
who occupy this building.
In blue writing are the science
faculty and in green writing
the engineering
faculty-- blurred
lines between these
disciplines now so
it isn't appropriate to
use different shading
for these folks.
But this is a
remarkable collection
of people, extremely
talented in their fields
and also quite distinctive
in their willingness
to broaden and
engage researchers
across many different areas
of science and engineering
and technology development.
They're very ambitious.
They're very creative.
They're are a bit
unconventional.
Frankly speaking, you don't find
cancer research institutions
like this anywhere else.
Cancer research
institutions, in most places
look like a swim meet, where
everybody's more or less doing
the same stroke, staying in
their lane, with their heads
down.
Cancer research at MIT
and the Koch Institute
looks quite different.
Nobody's doing the same stroke.
Some people are doing
strokes you cannot recognize.
People are ripping
up the lane markers.
Angie Belcher is
lighting them on fire.
Mike Yaffe and Paul Hammond
are diving off the high board
doing cannon balls
into the water.
Cancer research in the Koch
Institute looks different.
It's frankly a frothy mess.
[LAUGHTER]
And we like it that way.
We're doing different things
and we're changing the paradigm.
We're changing how we're
approaching the cancer problem,
bringing the inventiveness,
the innovation, the spirit
and creativity of
MIT together to solve
these longstanding problems
in a different way.
Now it's not only about what's
happening inside the building.
The Koch serves as the National
Cancer Institute designated
cancer center for MIT.
And therefore we organize
the cancer research efforts
on campus.
And in this way we reach
out to cancer researchers
across the campus.
And there's more than
1,000 cancer researchers
at MIT in fact.
A full 27 faculty are extramural
members of the Koch Institute.
It's very much about
collaboration, collaboration
across disciplines, across
buildings, across the campus.
And collaboration is very
important to what we do.
It allows us to take
advantage of the creativity
of our colleagues independent
of where they come from.
And there is this
magic at the interface
if you're open to seeing it,
this collective creativity.
We see it at play every day.
And don't discount the
importance of beer--
extremely important as well.
The collaborations include the
folks within our communities,
but importantly, and especially
as we translate our ideas
out from MIT beyond,
we actually need
to collaborate
with other people.
We don't have a cancer
hospital at MIT.
We don't take care of
cancer patients here.
And so in order to be able to
do more clinically relevant
research, we must reach out.
And we've done that in lots of
different ways, in particular
with respect to the
Bridge Project, which
is a project that we
have in collaboration
with the Dana-Farber
Harvard Cancer Center.
And here we've funded
teams of investigators.
Soon that number will be up to
about 25 teams of investigators
between MIT and Harvard tackling
more clinically proximal
problems.
And this again brings our
ideas and our discoveries
directly to the
benefit of patients.
We also reach out to industry.
And these interactions
are also really important.
There's only so many things
we can do in our labs.
Sometimes we need the
capital and the expertise
of people from industry.
And so we've engaged with
bio-pharmaceutical partners
in a fairly significant way.
And we've also spun out
a bunch of companies.
This is a list of companies
that have spun out
of the Koch Institute,
intramural and extramural labs,
only since 2007.
There's about 42 companies
shown here, amazing to me.
Bob Langer has
started 35 of them.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
We're very proud of this fact.
Again, it advances
our work more quickly
to where it can make
the biggest difference.
So these kinds of approaches--
organizational structures are
really important, but
so too is the culture.
Phil Sharp reminded us
early on that culture
beats strategy every time,
and he's absolutely right.
And so we've tried to build
a culture of collaboration
within the Koch.
We have regular meetings
of students and post-doc
presenting their ideas to the
audience at large-- an audience
that involves people from
different disciplines.
And each time they
learn something new.
And each time they walk away
thinking about something
differently.
This is part of the success.
And they also teach each
other in the process.
These are two
examples of programs
run by students and
post-docs in the labs,
again teaching each other
about the problems they
know and the others
might not so well.
And so this kind of
environment, this culture
that we've created I think
is part of the reason
why the Koch has worked.
And I'm extremely proud and
grateful to all the people
who've contributed.
All right.
So that's the Koch introduction.
We're now going to switch
gears and talk about science.
And because we're going to
switch gears and it's at MIT,
it's appropriate that we
start with a test question.
So here we are.
Which of the following diseases
claimed the most lives in 2015?
Is it A, HIV/AIDS, B,
tuberculosis, C, malaria,
or D, cancer?
Who thinks A?
B?
C?
D?
Libby, what's the answer?
D, cancer.
Of course it's cancer.
This is a cancer lecture
after all, for god's sake.
Cancer claims more lives in
the world than the other three
combined.
You might find that
hard to believe.
But about 8.2 million people
lost their lives worldwide
to cancer.
That number is actually
going up sadly.
So cancer is a big problem.
It's the kind of
problem that MIT
should be investing in time and
energy and resources to solve.
So I need to give you a
little bit of a primer.
This is an audience
that is diverse,
coming from different areas.
So I want to start
with the basics
and then we'll move
ahead to talk about some
of the cancer research that
we've pursued in our lab.
So cancer cells arrive
from normal cells
and acquire changes that allow
them to divide inappropriately.
That's what cancer is.
It's an inappropriate
accumulation of cells.
Too many cells in the blood, too
many cells in a tissue, a mass.
This process of uncontrolled
cell division and cell
accumulation is driven by
changes in genes-- changes
in the genes that control
the normal behavior of cells.
And there are two
classes of genes
that are classically involved
in cancer development--
oncogenes which drive
the process forward.
These genes become activated--
hyper-activated in cancer.
And then there are
tumor-suppressor genes
that normally act to
restrain this process.
They get inactivated in cancer.
They get eliminated.
So these two classes of genes
underlie the development
of all cancers.
This is the genetic
basis of the disease.
In addition, cancer cells
don't grow up in isolation.
They grow up inside
tissues in your body.
And as such they
interact with the quote,
normal cells of your body too.
And these interactions turn
out to be extremely important.
They help the incipient
cancer cell evolve.
And in some cases
they try to inhibit
the development of those cells.
Immune cells, for
example, can both promote
and try to eliminate cancer
cells during their evolution.
So cancer is a complex
process-- the inner workings
of the cancer cell, as
well as the interactions
between the cancer cell and
the cells that surround it.
In addition, cancer
cells typically
don't stay where they start.
They move in the
process of metastasis
to other sites in the body.
And metastasis is actually
the lethal phase of cancer.
About 90% of cancer
deaths are attributable
to the metastatic
phase of the disease.
It's a phase that we don't
actually understand very well.
And we at MIT are actually
devoting a lot of energy
to understand that
process better.
I'm going to return to this
slide at several points
in the lecture to show
you how we in the lab
are approaching these
questions through the models
that we've developed.
A bit more background--
these genes
that I mentioned lie
within your chromosomes.
When you're born your cells
have the proper genetic dowry
assembled on 23
pairs of chromosomes.
Those chromosomes are painted
different colors here.
This is what a normal
karyotype looks like.
Cancer cells have
problems with their DNA.
Here's an example
of a cancer cell
which has way too
many chromosomes.
You can appreciate that.
This is called aneuploidy.
Angelika Amon in
our institute is
studying the details
of aneuploidy
and how it
contributes to cancer.
You can also see certain
structural changes in the DNA,
like this chromosome
here which is made up
of two different colors.
This is what's called
a translocation, where
one piece of one chromosome has
been stuck to a different one.
This creates a new
gene, likely an oncogene
which is driving these
cancer cells forward.
Here's another example of a
chromosomal spread of a cancer
cell.
And you can see that these
chromosomes are all screwed up.
There's multiple colors.
This is genetic haywire.
It's amazing that cancer
cells can actually
live with all this chromosomal
damage and yet they do.
They grow and ultimately
caused severe damage.
Now within all of
those changes, we now
know from massive
sequencing efforts
of the genomes of thousands of
cancer specimens-- much of that
done at the Broad
Institute-- that there
are about 600 genes
that are mutated
at significant frequency
across all human cancer.
So 600 of the about 22,000
genes that are in your genome
are directly contributing to
one or another form of cancer.
That's a pretty large number.
And that actually represents
some of the difficulties, some
of the challenge that we
cancer researchers face,
is to figure out the
contributions of all
of those different
genes in order
to be able to
understand the process
and hopefully do
something about it.
One of the promises
of figuring that out,
once you understand the
molecular basis of cancer,
is that you might be
able to treat it better.
If you can figure out exactly
what's driving a cancer,
you might be able to
make a medicine that
overcomes that effect, that
directly inhibits that effect.
This is the so-called idea
of precision cancer medicine.
And we're in era of precision
cancer medicine today.
There are new drugs
that can counteract
the effects of
particular changes
in certain genes
in certain cancers.
Importantly, among the earliest
of these precision cancer
medicines, two were based
on discoveries made at MIT.
HER2, a gene discovered
in Bob Weinberg's lab
is the target of a breast
cancer drug called Herceptin.
It works extremely
well in women who have
that particular alteration.
It's useless for
women who don't.
BCR-ABL is a small
molecule drug that
inhibits the function
of an enzyme that's
overactive in certain leukemias.
The enzyme ABL was discovered
in David Baltimore's lab here
at MIT.
Crizotinib treats a certain
form of lung cancer based
on a particular alteration.
I'm particularly
proud of that one
because the
international study that
was done to lead to the
approval of this drug
was carried out
by Alice Shaw, who
used to be a post-doc
in my lab and is now
an independent investigator
at the Mass General Hospital.
So we're in an era
now where we've
translated this basic
understanding of cancer
genetics to some, but not
yet enough new medicines that
are more effective
and less toxic
than standard chemotherapy.
Now this process of cancer
genes and cancer genetics
has a long history.
Our understanding goes
back many, many years.
It actually goes back
to this institution.
The first cancer gene was
discovered by Bob Weinberg.
He found it in a study
published here with Chiaho Shih
while Bob's lab was still
in the cancer center.
This was the first demonstration
that cancer cells, human cancer
cells have altered genes.
This really set the
field in motion,
and frankly set my
career in motion.
I was an undergraduate when
this study was published.
And Bob came and gave
a lecture and a course
that I attended and
described this work.
And it was based
on that work that I
decided I would become
a cancer researcher.
So I owe it all to you, Bob.
A few years later, Bob's
lab cloned the first tumor
suppressor gene in collaboration
with Ted [INAUDIBLE] lab.
This is the retinoblastoma
tumor suppressor gene.
A few years later
David [INAUDIBLE]
lab cloned the second or third
tumor suppressor gene, WT-1.
So MIT researchers have
contributed significantly
to the discovery of cancer
genes over the years.
The retinoblastoma gene falls as
a good example of a gene that's
mutated not only in sporadically
occurring cancers, where
there's no family history of
the disease-- this gene is
responsible for the
development of a rare tumor
of the eye, retinoblastoma.
But also you can
inherit from one parent
a defective copy of
this gene, and thereby
have a familial predisposition
to retinoblastoma.
And that disease looks
something like this.
This is a child with
so-called bilateral multifocal
retinoblastoma.
This child has tumors in both
eyes, probably about a dozen
in total.
And this is due to the
fact that the child
has inherited one defective
copy of the retinoblastoma tumor
suppressor gene from one
parent, and is therefore just
one mutational event away from
lacking this gene altogether.
And when that happens
the tumors develop.
When this work was
done in Bob's lab,
I decided that this is
what I wanted to study.
And I decided actually
to come back to Boston,
come back to MIT and join
Bob's lab to study this disease
and particularly familial
predisposition to cancer--
the genetic basis of cancer.
And I used techniques
that had been developed
by other people in
the field to allow
us to manipulate the genes
of mice in particular.
We can do this in other
species now, but at the time
we could really
only do it in mice.
I won't go through the
details of these studies,
but suffice it to say
that we can manipulate
the genomes of mice by adding
extra genes, oncogenes,
or deleting certain genes,
tumor-suppressor genes,
and by virtue of that make
those mice cancer-prone.
And that's what these two
studies published by other labs
demonstrate.
So I decided that I
would use the techniques
of genetic engineering in
mice to make models of cancer
that we could then use to study
the disease process in ways
that are difficult to
do in human beings.
So the idea was to create
genetically engineered mice
with mutations in
cancer genes, create
models of various
types of cancer,
and then study those models.
And over the years we've
studied many different cancer
types-- lung cancer,
which is going to be
a theme of today's lecture.
We also study pancreas cancer,
sarcomas, ovarian cancer,
brain cancer, retinoblastoma I
mentioned, and several others.
Now once you have
these strains of mice
that are genetically
engineered to be cancer-prone
you can use them for various
things, including for example,
studying tumor development.
And that was really the main
purpose at the beginning.
We don't understand the
process of tumor development
well enough.
It's hard to study that
process in a human being.
But with a mouse
model you can do it
because you can access the
disease at various stages.
You can look at the
diseased cells in ways
you can't easily do in
people and so forth.
So you can understand what
we call tumor progression
through the analysis
of these mouse models.
In addition, once
you have them, they
can be very useful practically.
You can use these models to
understand early detection.
Maybe I can find the
disease in an earlier stage
then it becomes
clinically evident.
That would be highly useful.
And we'll return to that topic.
Maybe we can figure
out new therapies
to treat the disease
more effectively.
If I understand the process
better by these mouse models,
maybe I can use a new
therapy to block it, and then
use that new therapy in
humans more effectively.
Or maybe I can prevent
the disease altogether.
If I understand the process
really, really well,
and be able to
anticipate it, maybe I
can actually intervene
before it gets
to an advanced stage in the
form of cancer prevention.
And we'll turn to
those topics as well.
So the first mouse I
made-- which by the way
took four years of my
life, back-breaking effort,
Bob will remember.
He's smiling.
Thanks a lot for that.
Nothing worked for
me in Bob's lab.
I blame him.
Nothing worked for me.
But we struggled on
and we made this mouse
that had a germ line mutation
in the retinoblastoma gene
with a full expectation that
the animals would develop
retinoblastoma, a tumor of eye.
In fact they did develop
cancer, pituitary tumors
at 100% frequency, thyroid
tumors at 50% frequency.
But amazingly enough,
not a single one of them
developed retinoblastoma.
And frankly speaking,
that was frustrating.
Now we went on, over
the next several years
to figure out why it was
that mice with a germ line
mutation in retinoblastoma, the
genetic analogs of that child
that I showed you
a few minutes ago,
actually don't develop
retinoblastoma.
And the answer is because there
are two other retinoblastoma
related genes that go by the
imaginative names of p107
and p130.
These are structurally
similar to Rb
and functionally overlapping.
Some of that work's shown by
Jackie Lee's here at the Koch.
And it turns out
that in a mouse,
for some reason in
the mouse, they can
cover for loss of Rb function.
So it turns out that you have
to get rid of 107 or 130,
in combination with
Rb, and when you
do that, finally in the hands
of David MacPherson in the lab,
you get retinoblastomas.
It took 15 years
for us to get there
but we eventually succeeded.
And so by sort of
understanding the underlying
biology and the
underlying genetics,
we could improve these
models over time.
And that's been an
ongoing theme for us.
A major focus since I
moved to the cancer center
and then on to the Koch
has been lung cancer.
Lung cancer is a major
cancer type in the US.
It's responsible for about
160 cancer deaths in the US,
more than a million worldwide.
Of course smoking is a major
carcinogen for lung cancer,
responsible for about
90% of cancer deaths.
There are various types of lung
cancer, small cell lung cancer,
non-small cell lung cancer.
You might have
heard these terms.
The type that we
studied most extensively
is called adenocarcinoma.
It's one of the non-small
cell lung cancers.
It happens to be the most
frequent of the lung cancers.
And we know a bit about
the genetics that underlie
this form of lung cancer.
We know, based on genome
sequencing analysis,
for example, that two genes
are frequently mutated.
K-ras, which is one of
these oncogenes that
drives the process forward, and
p53, which is one of the tumor
suppressor genes that
normally blocks the process
and is inactivated in cancers.
I also mentioned a couple of
other genes here, EGFR and ALK.
These occur at lower
frequency in lung cancers.
I mention them because
they are the target
of some of these targeted
therapies for lung cancer.
There are drugs that treat
these hyperactive genes.
But based on the frequent
mutation of K-ras and p53
we decided that we would study
those genes in the development
of lung cancer.
And we made a mouse
that we study now very
extensively in my lab.
There's a little bit of
scientific detail on the slide.
It doesn't really matter.
Suffice it to say that
we made a mouse that
has genetically engineered
copies of the K-ras
oncogene and the p53
tumor suppressor gene.
But in the native state
those don't do anything
to the cells of these
animals, including
the cells of the lung.
However they're triggered to be
activated in the case of K-ras
and inactivated in
the case of p-53.
And the trigger occurs by virtue
of these little triangular
shapes here.
These are called loxP sites.
And when this enzyme
called Cre acts
to loop out those
sequences, this K-ras gene
goes from off to on, and the
p53 tumor suppressor gene
goes from on to off.
And that's enough to
initiate a cancer.
And therefore over
time in these animals
we get lung tumors in the
lung, and over further time
we see these tumors
progress to metastasize.
And so this is a model that
we've now studied extensively
to understand the various steps
of lung cancer development.
We've studied this many ways,
by investigators, some of whom
are in the room,
over many years.
This is the contributions
of the K-ras
oncogene to the early
stages of tumor development.
This is actually a baby
picture of a tumor,
contributed by Carla Kim,
sitting right over there.
This is the very earliest
steps of response
to K-ras activation--
hyper-proliferation
of those cells.
They form these little layers of
abnormally over-growing cells,
benign tumors called
adenomas that progress
to larger adenomas.
We now know that if you
inactivate the p53 tumor
suppressor gene,
those tumors will
progress from a benign
state to a malignant state.
They go from benign
to real cancer.
p53 controls that transition.
And over the years
others have contributed
our understanding of many
of these various steps,
these arrows.
We're developing sort of
a molecular cartography
of cancer development
here, filling
in the pieces of this puzzle.
And we now understand
it actually quite well.
Now why do we
bother to understand
what these steps are, these
various active pathways, genes
that become hyper-expressed?
And the reason is, as
I mentioned before,
that if we can understand that
in detail, in the mouse model
and ultimately in
people, we might
be able to treat this
disease more effectively.
Now I work on mouse models.
And many people believe,
and I bet many of you
realize that there's a long
history of slamming mouse
models of cancer.
Many people think that it's
really easy to cure cancer
in mice, and therefore
it's not really worth
doing the experiment
in mice if it's not
going to prove true in humans.
In fact, those
statements are based
on primitive models, primitive
mouse models of cancer.
These models are much more
faithful to the actual disease.
They look much
more similar, both
genetically and
histopathologically and related
to the various cells that are
interacting with the tumor.
And so for all those
people who think
that it's really easy
to cure cancer in mice,
I say cure this.
And I've actually put my
money where my mouth is.
I've offered $10,000 to anybody
who can cure this model.
I never offer my own money.
Today I will offer
President Rief's money.
[LAUGHTER]
He's tapping David Koch on the
shoulder, I'll have you know.
Many have tried, no one
has succeeded to date.
It's very difficult to do.
Cancer is a tough challenge.
We've tried as well.
Here's two quick
examples-- inhibitors
against one of those
pathways called
NF-kappa B, inhibitors
against another
of those pathways I mentioned
that gets hyperactivated, went.
These extend lifespan of
mice as you can see here.
Animals that are untreated
succumb to their disease,
in this case within
about 100 days.
If you treat with
this small molecule
drug or this small molecule drug
the animals live a bit longer.
This is clearly not
curative but it's
a step in the right direction.
And we think that these
treatments, perhaps
in combination with
other treatments
might actually get us to
something that could be useful.
And we're encouraging our
pharmaceutical partners
to pursue these drugs actually
for the study of treatment
in humans.
These two drugs
fall into a class.
We call them small
molecule inhibitors.
They're useful in
binding to enzymes
that get hyperactive in cancer
cells in turning them off.
They fit like a lock in a key.
There's another class
of cancer drugs,
the antibody-based drugs.
These are much larger
biological molecules.
Herceptin is an example.
They can bind to
proteins on the outside
of cells that get hyperactivated
and turn them off.
These are good and where they
can be used can be powerful,
but they're quite limited.
It's not always easy to find
an enzyme that's hyperactive
in cancer cells in
order to drug it,
or to find a protein on the
surface of cells you could
that you can inhibit
by an antibody.
It would be nice
if we had a tool
that we could use to
turn off the expression
of all genes that are
hyperactive in cancer cells.
And it turns out, in part based
on discoveries from MIT alums,
including folks trained by
Bob Horovitz and Phil Sharp,
that there is a
new class of drugs
emerging, so-called RNA-based
drugs-- small RNA molecules
that can bind to and
inhibit target mRNAs
and cause either
their functional
silencing or their
activation, their elimination.
And if you could get these
small RNAs into cancer cells,
you might be able to
turn off an oncogene.
There's another class
of RNAs called microRNAs
which can silence pathways that
get hyperactivated when tumor
suppressor genes are lost.
If you could put a microRNA
inside a cancer cell
that lacked a particular
tumor suppressor gene,
you might be able to
correct the defect caused
by the loss of that
tumor suppressor gene.
And so we decided
some years ago to see
if this could work,
in particular using
these small interfering RNAs
to target ras in this model,
or a microRNA that can
substitute at least in part
for the loss of p53.
Now the difficulty is that it's
hard to get these microRNAs
into cancer cells in the body.
If you stick a naked RNA into
the blood, it gets degraded.
If you package it
up in certain things
it mostly goes to the liver.
It's fine for treating
liver disease,
and Phil actually helped
start a company called Alnylam
that is developing
liver-based treatments using
this very strategy.
But if you want to treat cancers
of the lung or somewhere else
that's tricky.
Now fortunately in the
Koch we have many folks
who are developing
new strategies
to deliver various
things, including
these small RNAs to tumor
cells outside of the liver.
And Dan Anderson's lab has
been one of the pioneers,
along with Bob Langer's lab.
And in Dan's lab,
James Dahlman developed
a particular
nanoparticle that they
showed was able to
carry these small RNAs,
not just to the liver but
to other places, including,
importantly here, the lung.
So Wen Xue in my lab
collaborated with James Dahlman
and tested the ability
of nanoparticles
that were loaded
up with microRNA 34
or si-RNAs RNAs against
K-ras, or the combination
to treat effectively the lung
cancers in this model system.
And sure enough, when
we treat these animals
with multiple doses-- animals
caring establish tumors--
in contrast to control tumors
that contribute continue
to grow, the miR34 treated
tumors show growth inhibition.
So this small RNA
therapy actually works.
It slows the growth
of these tumors.
Likewise if we inhibit K-ras
with this si-RNA against K-ras
we can see a tumor
growth inhibition.
If we combine those
two, we can actually
see tumor regression taking
place-- an RNA-based treatment
for cancer.
This opens up a
whole new strategy
for the treatment of this
and many other cancers.
And with respect to
longevity as well,
we can expand the lifespan,
as well as those drugs.
In fact better than those drugs
that I showed you previously.
Now you would think that this
would be an attractive strategy
for pharmaceutical companies.
We actually tried to attract
pharmaceutical companies
to support this work
and translate this work.
The scientists in that
particular company
were really interested and
then the lawyers got involved.
And sadly they killed
the project for reasons
that I can explain later.
But this I think is a
promising new approach
to the treatment of
this and hopefully
many other types of cancer.
So I want to switch gears
and talk about this process
of cancer genetics.
Cancer genes as I mentioned
are a very important process
in tumor development
most broadly.
This subject has become
much more complex
of late, in part because cancer
genome sequencing studies have
revealed that many, many
genes-- I mentioned this
before-- many, many
genes are mutated
in various types
of human cancer.
In lung cancer, for
example, the average tumor
has about 175
protein-altering mutations.
That's a bewildering
collection of changes.
And it makes it
difficult for people
like those in my lab to
think about how to study
that process systematically.
How do we look at all
of those different genes
and their particular
contributions to cancer?
And the reason it's
hard is that the way
we do that or have
done that in the lab
is to make mice with
mutations in those genes,
and then to cross those
mice with the mice that
are cancer-prone, and then
test the contributions
of those mutations to
the tumorigenic process.
That process would take two
to three years for every gene
that you want to study.
And that was bewildering to us.
And frankly a bit discouraging.
And around this time, as we
realized the daunting challenge
that lay ahead of us, those
in the lab became depressed.
The skies above
us were darkening.
And we didn't know
quite what to do.
So I called Ted Cruz.
[LAUGHTER]
And he said, "look to
the heavens and pray."
So we did.
And sure enough, the skies
brightened and delivered
unto us was a tool,
and it's called CRISPR.
Now I'll go through
this quite quickly.
CRISPR is a remarkable
new tool available
to biological scientists.
It's based on a
system in bacteria
that leads to the inactivation
of viruses that are trying
to infect the bacterial cells.
Various workers have
perfected this system
and morphed it into a form
where it can be used effectively
in mammalian cells.
This work was carried
out by many labs,
including Feng Zhang's
lab here at MIT,
but important contributions by
Jennifer Doudna and Emmanuelle
Charpentier, George
Church and others.
We now have this
tool which allows
us to inactivate and actually
modify by surgical precision,
essentially any gene
of the genome in ways
that we couldn't have
envisioned before.
And this technology
is sweeping the field.
There have been, since
these publications--
which are just about three
years ago-- 2,500 papers
published on this
CRISPR technology.
We in the lab decided
to see if we could make
this work in our mouse models.
And [INAUDIBLE] and Francisco
Sanchez-Rivera and colleagues
decided to use the
KP model to see
whether we could make it work.
And again, without going through
the details of how it was done,
we created a virus that carried
the CRISPR components, in order
to bring those CRISPR components
directly into the cancer cells
as they were developing, and
thereby hopefully inactivate
any old gene of interest, as
those cancers were evolving.
And they did that with a variety
of different genes of interest.
And that's shown here.
And each time they
did it the cancers
changed in a distinctive
and measurable way
as a function of the particular
gene that we were targeting.
In all in this experiment,
which took about seven months
to complete, after maybe
a month of planning,
we generated hundreds
of cancer samples
which we could then interrogate
by various biochemical methods
and study with respect to
their response to treatments.
This same experiment using
the old fashioned techniques
would've taken us
years to do and cost
multiple hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
So this has completely
changed the way
that we are prosecuting genes
of interest in my lab and labs
around the world.
It is fast-tracking our
understanding of cancer.
One of the reasons we're excited
about how quickly we will
become able to come to
solutions for cancer
is based on this technology.
I'm going to spend
just a minute or so
mentioning one
particular collaboration
that involved this phase of the
process of cancer development--
the metastatic phase, that
last stage, that lethal phase
of cancer.
We're very interested
in that phase.
But I want to mention
one particular project
that I'm excited about because
it underscores collaboration
and technology.
I was sitting around
with colleagues
in the lunch line at the Koch
Institute-- Scott Manalis
and Matt Vander
Heiden explaining
that would be interesting if
we could build a device that we
could plug into the
blood system of a mouse
and see whether there
were circulating tumor
cells in the blood to be able
to measure them, quantify them.
To do it longitudinally to see
what the change of those cell
numbers were over
time and see what
their response to treatment was.
This is sort of a
pie in the sky idea.
But testament to the
creativity of the Koch culture,
Scott Manalis said, "I
think we can do that."
Sort of a can-do attitude.
And then he went off and did it.
And that's what you're
looking at here.
This is a device which
is plugged into the blood
system of a cancer-bearing
mouse that can actually
measure circulating
tumor cells in real-time
and longitudinally.
It's not just an idea.
It actually works.
You can actually
see these cells.
And you can actually
capture the cells
by activating these
various ports.
And then you can
study the biology
of those cells using various
molecular techniques, including
as we've done here in
Alex Shalek's lab looking
at the RNA expression
of individual
circulating tumor cells.
This is just an example of
a technology that comes out
of the kinds of
collaborations that we have
available to us in the Koch.
I mentioned earlier
that the interactions
between cancer cells and other
cells are very important.
In particular, the immune cells.
Immune cells of the
body have the potential
to recognize and
eliminate cancers.
The hope is that
we can stimulate
that to happen more effectively.
And, in fact, that is
starting to happen.
You might know that
cancer immunotherapy
is a very powerful new
approach to the disease.
Science Magazine declared
cancer immunotherapy one
of the breakthroughs
of that year.
And the reason is
that there are now
new agents, including
FDA-approved drugs that
can effectively stimulate
an immune response
against your cancer.
Here's an example of one.
This is a study carried out
just this past year, which
led to the approval of
this particular drug, which
is an antibody against an
immune checkpoint called PD-1.
And you can see patients
treated with this drug
do much, much better
then those treated
with standard chemotherapy.
These patients with lung cancer
have failed previous therapy.
But when treated with this
drug, even after a couple years,
30% of them are alive,
compared to the control
where just 10% are.
And we know from other studies
that these patients are likely
going to have durable
cures, or durable responses
in some cases-- cures.
So these drugs
have really started
to change the way we
think about our prospects
for controlling cancer by
stimulating the immune cells.
The action is right here.
There are T-cells
cells in your body
they can attack foreign cells.
And your cells, your cancer
cells become foreign.
If you can stimulate T-cells
to attack your cancer cells,
that's a good thing.
So we got excited
about the prospect
of studying the tumor immune
interface with our mouse
models.
And so Michael [INAUDIBLE]
and Anne Chung and others
built models to stimulate
immune responses against cancer.
John Proctor funded
some of that early work.
This was done by
manipulating those viruses
that we use to start the
process at the beginning.
And this actually does work.
If you introduce into
these tumors antigens
that the immune system can see,
you can attract immune cells
to the tumors.
You can actually get
T-cells into the tumor
micro-environment.
And they're not just bystanders.
They're actually
doing something.
You can measure an
anti-tumor response
by those infiltrating T-cells.
They're attacking the
tumor just like we
want them to do, for a while.
But eventually, and not
very long thereafter,
they fail to sustain
that response.
The number of those
tumor-reactive T-cells drops.
Their activity states drop.
They become-- and this is a
technical term-- exhausted.
They're there, but
they're not functioning.
And so we decided we would
investigate this process.
And various investigators--
Michael, Amy Lee, Nik Joshi
and others have looked
at the system in our lab.
There are various ways that the
immune system can get shut off
in the development of cancer.
Here's a list of them.
These checkpoints get activated.
Various cells of the
micro-environment
turn off immune function.
One of those checkpoints
that I actually mentioned,
PD-1, does in fact get
up-regulated in the T-cells
at that late time point.
But Amy Lee has actually
tried that anti-PD-1 antibody
and it doesn't work
in this system.
So this is a challenge to
understand why it doesn't work,
and what we might be
able to do about it.
Nik Joshi has asked
whether a different cell,
a different mechanism,
in this case a cell
called a regulatory
T-cell might be
involved in turning
off the immune response
in an established tumor.
First he measured the quantity
of these regulatory T-cells
in the tumor and found that
they were, in fact, highly
increased.
In tumor-bearing mice
at this late stage
is about a 20-fold increase in
T-regulatory cells in the tumor
micro-environment at the time
the T-cells get exhausted.
That's guilt by association.
But in these mouse models
we can do experiments.
And Nik was able to deplete
the T-regulatory cells
and ask what the
consequences of getting rid
of that inhibitory
cell type was.
This is the before picture.
The tumor cells are
nice and juicy red.
The T-cells in green are sitting
on the sidelines exhausted,
not controlling the tumor.
He could then get rid of
the T-regulatory cells
by this method.
And when he did so he saw this.
The immune cells now
increase the number
and infiltrated into the tumor.
And when they did so they caused
massive tumor destruction.
So T-regulatory cells are
controlling an immune response
in this model system, likely
in human cancers as well,
and we're now
trying to figure out
ways of specifically
inactivating regulatory T-cells
in the tumor micro-environment
to be able to translate
this for use in people one day.
All right.
I'm coming to the
end of the hour.
I just want to mention two very
brief projects, both of which
are nascent projects in the
lab, a view towards the future,
and also underscore the
collaborations that we have
available to us at the Koch.
And the first involves
a collaboration
with Sangeeta Bhatia's
lab on this process
of early detection.
If we could eliminate cancers
at a very early stage, when
they're, for example,
surgically respectable,
our success rates
would go way up.
But we need to be able to
find those cancers earlier.
And Sangeeta's lab is developing
nanotechnology-based strategies
to do that.
And they published
some of this work,
but not as it
relates to the lungs.
So this is unpublished data.
And what they do is to take
an aerosolized nanoparticle
and introduce it into ultimately
humans-- in these experiments
mice-- into the lungs of
tumor-bearing or non-animals.
These nanoparticles have
little tags on them,
shown in red here.
And these tags
can be clipped off
by an enzyme-- this little
Pac-Man thing-- an enzyme that
gets up-regulated in the
cancers specifically.
If the tags get
clipped off, they
can now get excreted
into the urine
and detected in the urine.
And then by a simple
urine test one
can find the evidence
of a tumor in the lung.
Seems crazy, but actually, in a
collaboration involving Andrew
Warrem and [INAUDIBLE]-- they
tested this idea by allowing
mice with these lung tumors
to inhale the nanoparticles,
and then tested them,
either at three weeks,
when the tumors are tiny, or
at six weeks or at seven weeks
to see whether this was a signal
of nanoparticle activation.
And lo and behold,
at three weeks
there's not much of a
signal but at six weeks
you can clearly see it.
At seven weeks it's
undeniable that you
can detect cancers in
these mice by this very
simple nanoparticle-based
aerosolized urine test.
I should mention that we make
the undergraduates collect
the urine.
[LAUGHTER]
Kidding about that.
So I'm excited about early
detection opportunities.
And finally, I'm excited about
prevention opportunities.
I think among the
projects in the lab,
I'm excited about all of them.
I'm probably most
excited about the idea
that we can actually
prevent cancers one day.
And this a project
that's in the hands
of David Cantor in my
lab, in collaboration
Omar Khan and [INAUDIBLE] who
work in the Anderson and Langer
labs in the Koch Institute.
And the idea, which
I'm just going
to give you in concept
form, is that we've
learned a lot about how these
tumors evolve in this mouse
model.
And there's one particular
protein shown here
called Hmga2, which
gets regularly
up-regulated in
late stage cancers.
It's not there in the
early stage tumors.
But as shown in
the brown staining
it becomes expressed
in more than half
of these late stage tumors.
Now the important
thing you need to know
is that Hmga2 is not
normally expressed anywhere
in the adult animal.
It's only expressed
in the embryo.
But it becomes abnormally
up-regulated in the tumor.
And so the question is,
if we know that's coming,
can we vaccinate
the mouse such that
when it sees that it will
eliminate those cancer cells?
Prophylactic vaccination,
preventative vaccination
based on our knowledge
of what's coming,
just like vaccination
against infectious disease.
And so David and
his collaborators
are now doing the experiment
of taking the KP mouse
and vaccinating it with
this protein, Hmga2.
So we'll get an immune
response against Hmga2.
And then we would induce
tumors in these mice,
and ask whether, in
fact, we can protect them
against the development
of advanced cancers.
If this works it
will suggest that we
could do similar
things in human beings,
and one day perhaps we will.
And if you like that
idea, I encourage
you to consider coming
to our symposium in June
on the subject of prevention
and early detection of cancer.
So I've come up to
the end of the hour.
I'm going to thank--
just two more slides.
The work that I described to you
requires tremendous resources
and I've received tremendous
resources and support
from many places, including
importantly the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute,
the National Cancer
Institute, the Lustgarten
Foundation, tremendous support
from the Koch
Institute including
the Swanson Biotechnology
Center and other funders.
And finally I'm going
to stop where I started.
Nothing I presented
to you could not
have been done by the collective
efforts of a tremendously
talented group of people.
And I want to thank them,
thank you, and thank you again
for the Killian award.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much Tyler.
I would ask people
with questions-- there
are microphones in both aisles.
There's one here and
there's one somewhere
right about where I'm
pointing there-- please
come to the microphones
and Tyler will be
happy to take some questions.
And if you prefer to shout, I'm
happy to repeat your question.
This side.
Can you tell us
whether or not cancers
are at all found in embryos?
And if not, is that
significant and does
that tell one anything?
The question is, are
cancers in embryos?
Occasionally yes-- occasionally.
But if you recall my earlier
comments about the fact
that cancers require the
acquisition of alterations
in genes, it's not surprising
that you wouldn't find them
very often, because
of the opportunity
for an embryonic cell to
acquire the necessary changes
to convert it from normalcy to
malignancy is very, very low.
It typically requires a long
time, years or even decades
to acquire the necessary damage.
At some frequency that
will happen in short term,
and so we do occasionally
see it, including in embryos
sometimes in
children as you know.
But those disease
are relatively rare.
If you're far away from a
mic, just raise your hand.
So as you know,
this immunotherapy
which is so exciting,
because it gives some cures,
doesn't work in a number
of cancer so far--
breast cancer, some hint in
prostate, but in many others
there's no hint at all.
Do you see the same sort of
Treg effects in those tumors
as you do in your model?
Yeah.
So the question is
a good one, Phil.
It relates to our
lack of understanding
of why immunotherapy works when
it works and not otherwise.
So you're asking whether
Tregs might contribute.
I think the answer
is likely yes.
Certainly there are cancer
epidemiological studies
that would suggest that
the presence of Tregs
correlates with
poorer prognosis,
and that would suggest the Tregs
may be inhibiting an otherwise
effective immune response.
I think that's
part of the answer.
There are likely other answers.
Why, in certain circumstances
the immune system can see
a tumor, and in
other cases it can't?
The immune system relies
on there being differences
between tumor and normal.
The more differences the better.
Lung cancer, where this
treatment works-- melanoma,
where this treatment
works, happen
to be two of the tumors that
are full of mutations, because
of the carcinogens of
smoke or of the sun.
So they're very different.
And that might be why the
immune system is particularly
good at seeing them.
But I think some of these
other suppressive mechanisms
are likely part of
the answer as well.
Yes, I speak to
you-- is this on?
Is it working?
Yes.
Oh.
--not as a biologist
but as an engineer,
and a recent pancreatic
cancer survivor.
Recently the vice president
announced a moonshot approach.
In reading the literature in
the popular press, et cetera,
I see a lot of negativity about
the approach to this moonshot,
namely that cancer is more
than 200 separate diseases
and largely unique
to the individual.
Can you give us a
comment on how this
is going to affect the future?
Yeah.
So I think that,
for one, we don't
have a very clear understanding
of what the moonshot
effort will look like.
We hope that it comes with
a significant increase
in funding.
And that will allow a variety
of things to be tried and tested
and accelerated.
So I think the
details still have
to come in to give you a
proper answer to your question.
I think some of the negativity
relates to our general concern
in the cancer research
community of trying
to put a timeline on anything.
These are hard problems.
And it's difficult to
say, with more money
we'll solve the problem
in two years or three.
Those things have
been made before
and I think they are unwise
and not very helpful.
So more funding and dedicated
efforts in certain areas--
immunotherapy's on that list.
Immunotherapy's very
promising, but we
have questions still to answer.
With more funding
and concerted effort
to understand some
of those questions,
will you be in a better place
to use those treatments,
maybe even in the short term.
Other things on that list are
early detection, I mentioned,
even prevention I mentioned.
Those areas don't get
enough funding right now.
And so maybe with
some additional funds
we can shift the curve
of diagnosis, or even
to prevention.
So I'm not a skeptic.
I'm an optimist.
And I'm happy that
the vice president
is talking about more funding.
That's always a good thing.
Do I see further hands?
Yes.
I guess one of the
cancer obviously
is that it's a
disease of the self.
And the immune system goes
through a [INAUDIBLE] selection
process so that you [INAUDIBLE].
So regarding this last
vaccine trial effort,
do you have any
experience, for instance,
indicating at which point do
tumors acquire immunoresistance
or [INAUDIBLE]?
And is this potential, even
when an earlier vaccine
is delivered for a tumor to
form and maintain a [INAUDIBLE]?
Hmga2.
So what I showed
you is a concept.
It's in very early stages.
You raised the question of self
versus non-self and tolerance.
We actually believe that we can
create a vaccine against Hmga2.
I won't talk about those
data because they're
very, very preliminary.
But I think it's possible
that we can at least get
the immune system to see Hmga2.
If we can, then the tumor will
be in an ongoing discussion
with the immune system.
Sometimes the immune
system will win,
and I think that
would be a good thing.
Sometimes the tumor will win.
And some of these
immuno-evasion mechanisms, Tregs
and other things
will come into play.
Maybe the tumors will lose
the expiration of Hmga2.
But sometimes they will
see a positive effect,
and that might lead to a
shift in the likelihood
that somebody who's,
for example predisposed
to particular cancer will
get it or how long it
will take them to get it.
So these might not be panaceas.
They may not solve the
problem for the reasons
that you're suggesting, but
I think they might well help,
and that's why
we're pursuing it.
So I'll ask a question
myself while I'm
looking for further hands.
So I see many in
the room whom I take
to be students and post-docs.
So thinking of all the students
and post-docs in the room,
could you sort of look
back on your own experience
and talk about how you
picked good problems
or how they find you?
Well, what I tell my
students and post-docs
is a little bit about my comment
about swimming in your lane
and keeping your head down.
I think it's good
to keep your head up
and swim out of your lane.
I think it's good to go
beyond, to challenge yourself
and to push beyond
the conventional.
So my students and
post-docs do things
that people have never
tried to do before.
And sometimes it's hard
and it takes a long time,
but usually with a good
idea and perseverance
you can get to the end.
So challenging yourself to
doing something difficult
is part of the answer.
Yeah.
I think in addition, just
related to the Koch concept,
keeping your mind open
to alternative approaches
from other fields.
I think I'm seeing
this more and more,
and I've given you
some examples, where
if you just focus
on what you know,
your blinding yourself to
many new opportunities.
Thank you.
Right in the middle there
and then I'll go back there.
Yes.
Looking at the
circulating tumor cells
that you discussed, and next to
sequencing and ultra-sensitive
[INAUDIBLE] from
DNA, do you think
it will be feasible
in the near future
to basically screen [INAUDIBLE]
cancers using these methods?
Yeah.
It's a great question.
Circulating tumor cells-- the
answer is likely yes, even now.
These cells are being
used to track the state
of an individual's tumor, now.
How many there are pre,
post-treatment for example.
Soon the circulating
DNA that you referenced
will be used in a
similar fashion.
In fact it already is
being used in that way.
And maybe before too
long, circulating DNA
will be used to test
whether somebody's
got an early staged cancer in
the form of early detection.
And one of our speakers
at our symposium
actually, Bert Vogelstein will
talk about that very approach.
So I think the answer is yes.
You worry a little bit
about what will you
detect, because if you
have an abnormal cell,
it's not yet a cancer.
Do you really want to know
that and intervene then?
So we need a little
bit more specificity
about what the
signal is telling us.
But the answer is, I think, yes.
Before long these tests will
be used, perhaps routinely.
Your annual checkup
could include sequencing
of your circulating DNA.
In fact, I'll bet on it.
And there was a
question right there.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm sorry can you say it again.
I didn't-- I didn't
hear the middle.
It's K-ras and p53, yes?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
So there's a detailed
question related
to the specific mechanisms
of activation or inactivation
of K-ras and p53.
Short answer to your question
is yes, there are differences.
So the exact way in
which you activate K-ras
changes its effect on the cell.
So different tumors do
it slightly differently.
Two tumors of the
same type that do it
with slightly
different mechanisms
can have different responses.
And P53 is similar actually.
The way that you
inactivate it can
influence the exact pathways
that cell will take.
Are there other questions?
Right here.
Yes.
There are many,
many different kinds
of mice that have
been developed.
Many, many different
kinds of mice
that have been developed
in your laboratory.
And if that's the case
then it seems to me
that there are many different
ways then that present
themselves as to how
to treat these mice,
and therefore develop a much
greater likelihood that you
can cure those kinds of mice.
Yeah.
Well that was one of
the motivations, David,
for creating these models.
We needed to have better
systems that we believed in,
that were faithful
to the human disease.
And the answer is that
now that we have them,
the treatments that we
can test, the likelihood
that the results that
we see in those models
will play out
eventually clinically
is much, much greater.
So we have much greater faith.
And that's really important
because right now there are too
many drugs to test in patients.
Phil mentioned immunotherapy.
There are so many
candidates and combinations
that could be
tested, it outstrips
the number of patients
that could be tested with.
And so we need better systems.
And that was actually
the motivation way back
when to create this model so we
can create predictive responses
for treatment to help
guide us to figure out what
to use eventually in patients.
Thank you very much.
Let me ask everyone to
join me in thanking you
for a wonderful lecture.
[APPLAUSE]
And congratulations again.